yeah welcome to this video Queens gambit
the triangle hmm should I allow the
notable the notorious notable it's not
going for it just playing the semi Slav
okay yeah I'm that many lines against
the sides laughs Kim let's play the Sun
and time Aaron eonni solid line yeah
black noise yep more than one way to
play 27 rookie age taking on c4 I'm
taking on c4 as the most popular move
but tick tick here is a night be five
annoying I don't only know this line I
mean I'm just playing it for the riot he
said hmm he just takes with this piece
yeah okay i can now exchange some pieces
and maybe retain a very slight edge okay
let's do that i takes just him yeah now
i'm basically threatening to 21 trade
everything only five so he i think he
needs to react to that maybe by taking
her if he takes on a three it's actually
helping my development and not sure that
this son this was a a good good term way
to play for blackness in early five aha
so 95 this should be true yeah looks
like mass mass mass mass exchanges yeah
many exchanges let's put it that way i
can i can trade everything if I like
okay that's not to lose on time while I
consider this yeah also could have taken
only five but this is maybe a bit bit
more precise so taking here I don't like
to take only five maybe I can can try to
provoke him into taking himself maybe
also Queen B 5 as an idea and one
problem for white and the structures
that I've played be three of course
there were there was no way to play it
to get to the position without the move
but it weakens the C 3 square and this
is a problem quite often Black has some
this idiom of invading on c3 with the
rook mostly or in positions where
they're more pieces on the board with
night now this would be much more
promising with the pawn on be too yeah
not much more promising but it's it's
better to have the pawn back on the
second-ranked yeah still this is a
position where I can try to press a bit
he's always suffering from the isolated
pawn yeah look that's the counter play
so try to protect see one he was maybe
getting in rooks he won himself so Queen
d2 and maybe I need to I need some some
lift for the King age 3 or something the
CFR counter play
the place rook c8 no I can take the five
and heavy for maybe form what are what
are you doing now but in fact I could
have played the last reason I could have
I could have played this one move
earlier I simply rocks if I this kind of
meeting the Queen self meeting the Queen
repay for I could have played it one
movie idea I was so busy with this
prophylactic move and then now I spotted
it Queen it's trapped yeah very sad
antium I need to probably move the Queen
back Roxy five isn't great problem yeah
everything else fails I can just grab it
him and I'm a pawn up yeah I'm not a lot
of theoretical expert him but I think if
I vs is not not well timed my not that
this is the end of the world black it's
not it's not lost or anything but this
seems like white should be a somewhat
somewhat more comfortable maybe add the
retreat is actually a man IDM something
like this I'll too bad mmm yeah but that
the NT yeah the light donated the Queen
to my course alright thanks for watching